how do you think life originated on
earth and what insights does that give
us about life
if we go back to the origin of earth and
you think about maybe 4.7 4.6 4.5
billion years ago planet was quite hot
there was a limited number of minerals
there was some carbon some water
and i think that maybe it's a really
simple set of chemistry that we we
really don't understand
so that means you've got a finite number
of elements that are going to react very
simply with one another
and out of that mess comes a cell so
literally sand turns into cells and it
seems to happen quick
so what i think i can say with some
degree of
i think not certainty but curiosity
genuine curiosity is that life happened
fast yeah so when we say fast
this is a pretty surprising
fact and maybe you can actually correct
me and elaborate but it seems like most
like 70 or 80 of the time that earth has
been around there's been life on it like
some very significant percentage so when
you say fast like the slow part is from
single cell
or from bacteria to some more
complicated organisms it seems like most
of the time that earth has been around
it's been single cell
or like very basic organisms like a
couple billion years but yeah you're
right that that's really i recently kind
of revisited
our history and saw this
and
i was just looking at the timeline wait
a minute like how did life just spring
up so quickly like really quickly that
makes me think that it really wanted to
like
put another way it's very easy for life
to spring
yeah i agree i think it's much more
inevitable and i think um i try to
kind of not provoke but try and push
chemists to think about because chemists
are part essential to this problem right
of understanding the origin of life on
earth at least because we're made of
made of chemistry but i wonder if the
origin of life
on a planet or sorry the emergence of
life on the planet is as
common as the formation of a star
and if you start framing it in that way
it allows you to then look at the
universe slightly differently because
and we can get into this i think in
quite some detail but i think i to to
come back to your question i have
little idea of how life got started but
i know it was simple
and i know that the process of selection
had to occur before
the biology was established so that
selection
built the framework from which life
kind of grew in complexity and
capability and functionality and
autonomy and i think these are all
really important words that we can
unpack over the next
while can you say all the words again so
he says
selection
so natural selection
the original a b testing and so and then
complexity
and then
the degree of autonomy and
sophistication because i think that
people misunderstand what life is
um
some people say that life is a cell and
some people that say that life is a
a virus or life is a you know an on off
switch
i don't think it's that life is the
universe developing a memory
and um the laws of physics and the way
well there are no laws of physics that
physics is just memory free stuff right
so there's only a finite number of ways
you can arrange the fundamental
particles to do the things life is the
universe developing
a memory so it's like
sewing
a piece of art slowly
and then you can look back at it so
so there's a stickiness to life it's
like universe doing stuff and when you
say memory it's like
there's a stickiness to a bunch of the
stuff that's building together yeah so
like you can
in a stable way like uh
trace back the complexity
and that tells a coherent story yeah and
i think yeah okay
that's by the way very poetic
and beautiful
life is the universe developing a memory
[Music]
okay and then there's autonomy you said
in complexity we'll talk about but
it's a really interesting idea that
selection preceded biology
you